[Music]
hey rick
i have to make a project for the science
fair this weekend you think you could
help me out science fairs
well i mean traditionally science fairs
are a
father-son thing so girls never have to
participate in science fairs
that's unfair fair and racist eating
pancakes with butter and no syrup
oh my god a brand new sentient robot
would say oh my gears
just saying whatever this guy is doing
balancing plates on thin air
i see they fixed the shelf but they
changed the animation so add another sin
i make my own stuff and the animators
make their stuff up on the spot too
the skull candle and a floating elephant
carcass
are brand new additions to this counter
i'm a man of science
and i'm a man who likes consistency why
is the elephant in a jar over here now
not to start a whole nother jif gift
debate but does the glue have a label on
it claiming to be
sticky giz or jizz
but you know spelled with a g for some
reason
why do we have to corrupt glue why does
glue have to be perverted
being limber enough to flop your legs on
the floor like this without pulling any
ligaments or dislocating your pelvis
jerry was inside the house and could
have walked through this door to the
garage but instead circles outside to
the garage to enter in dramatic fashion
is he smart enough to think about
entering for dramatic flair this
aftershave made women want me but it
also made me impotent
oh my god how can i not see this coming
because because you're impotent
this serum should counteract the
negative effects injecting someone with
your serum without their explicit
consent
i like my devil fights to have a lot
more finger zapping and brimstone and a
lot less back and forth slapping
so what was the ironic punishment for
buying the vase how does a scary ghost
go along with your theme
this vase helps your flower stay alive
but it's also haunted is a joke that
steps on the theme and you're just being
lazy
i'm king flippy nips ruler of pluto
we discovered you quite by accident
which is interesting because pluto was
also discovered quite by accident it was
when saturn was going in and out of
uranus and then about to hook up with
neptune
you really gave it to those guys at nasa
the plutonians abduct jerry so that he
can declare pluto a planet and i'm sure
that's amazing for their egos and all
but why do they think jerry has any sway
over the rest of earth didn't they hear
how nasa responded
this is what you do when your b story
has nowhere else to go well i'm going to
get the curses removed
at cursed purge plus you know the guy on
tv and of course rick is on the
television right this second because tv
show has to news position
but why she could have just as easily
said you know the store across the
street
as we find out that's where it is in
just a second also this tv wasn't even
on 20 seconds ago
[Applause]
but how exactly did rick get a store
bought up so fast rick is not the devil
he can't just make a store appear
overnight
also how is the shopping district if
first in maine had a vacancy
also also how did rick know mr needful
was going to this window at this exact
moment
the center of pluto mr smith is made of
a substance called plutonium
pluto exposition pluto's position
ex-pluto system
pluto goes from planet to asteroid to
meteor
and finally a great visual truly but
where did the pluto dust come from his
hands were empty a moment ago
oh my god that's the devil summer i wish
this desk was lighter
absolutely none of the wishes summer
makes on the monkeys paw come with any
backfiring curses
what a waste of a monkey poor but how
would mr needful know this
he was passed out while summer was
making her wishes mr needful how could
you even think of doing something so
horrible
i'm the devil can the devil even kill
himself if he's the devil it implies he
sort of lives forever
right i can take out the eternity and
the padding and then you'll have some
time traveling mittens
and at what point does anyone ask what
the cost for the item will be
these items are literally priceless and
not in a good way
i just got bored everybody out how
jeremy in cinemasins staff meetings
are you telling me four billion
plutonians are wrong
can we worry about that in just a second
because who's going to tell jerry to
stop putting scissors up his nose in a
moving vehicle
angry crowd suddenly has rotting food to
throw cliche
it was a long six hours but we've
overhauled needful things
into the globally compliant web 4.0
e-nominant needful.com investing in the
dot-com business in 2014.
when exactly did jerry's roof get
repaired when the plutonians showed up
initially they pulled jerry and morty
through the roof causing a lot of damage
he dumped me summer wipes clumpy mascara
drippage from beneath her eyes with the
simple wipe of her hand
i mean that's the most unrealistic thing
to happen in this entire episode
repeating a cycle of violence
repetitively
i put a curse on that plane that it's
gonna explode
what is my purpose i brought you into
this world
a machine that can think and feel
[Laughter]
we are laughing
i want an apology may i demand
penance you're watching right side of
the bed i'm grayson chisholm
take him to plutonium bay you can't
handle the truth